moi j'ai 22 ans aujourd'hui et donc a
priori en 2050 si je suis toujours là je
serai pas très très vieille j'aurais la
cinquantaine et en fait elles sont
contents les gens qui aujourd'hui
prennent des décisions à peu près cet
âge là et il se projette vraiment en
2050 comme dans un truc de génération
future mais c'est nous qui allons le
vivre ça le problème des coques le
problème des grandes réunions c'est
qu'on parle comme ça d'objectif on fait
des beaux textes des beaux discours tout
le monde et larmes aux yeux mais c'est
pas contraignant donc en fait c'est des
belles paroles c'est des profs d'amour
sans contrat de mariage et en fait
quelque part on s'est trompé après on
dit que ce modèle de consommation dans
lequel on s'est élevé cours à ma propre
perte et ben ok c'est pas grave on va en
inventer un autre on va essayer on va
saisir de ce monde et on va le faire
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a au pal
pour voir c'est quelque chose qu'on
prend ou qu'on laisse aux autres il faut
juste qu'on ait l'audace le courage et
et l'énergie de le faire
[Musique]